just a second let me make it a little
colder and then all well uh we'll
explore
the trash fire on top of a dumpster fire
on top of a you know a turkey rolled
into a chicken that's been happening in
the chess world
[Music]
this has been a crazy crazy three days
from the perspective of you know a chess
professional
because i you know i know a lot of
people my phone has been exploding the
last three days it's been
very anxiety provoking
i feel like i've been pegged to my phone
and there's just like all this stuff
happening i'm getting all these messages
on all these servers and i feel like if
i don't respond in five seconds
you know the person who's messaging me
will freak out
so it's been
honestly i cannot wait for this to end
one way or the other because a lot of
people live for this but people like me
who make their living just doing mundane
stuff like teaching chess and playing
blitz those are the things i actually
want to do
this is my least favorite thing to do
it's also the thing that i am worst at
managing this kind of drama when
people's emotions are you know just like
at a ridiculous level to the point where
like you can barely say anything because
thousands of of internet faces will get
unbelievably furious if they even
misinterpret a single word of what
you're saying so it's a very very
charged situation i want to approach it
very carefully
i you know in full disclosure i haven't
gathered any of my thoughts properly
let's get one thing out of the way
before i begin
my goal in presenting this issue my
perspective on this issue is that if
hans were watching the stream right now
and perhaps also if magnus who are
watching this stream right now
you know fans were watching the stream
and then anybody else who felt that
you know who felt very strongly one way
or the other they would all feel like
i'm being fair
so
i think the gold standard needs to be
you know the people involved are
actually watching you talk
will they acknowledge that you are being
fair and objective the answer is no then
you're already doing something wrong
you're already being biased
you're already letting your preconceived
notions taint your perception of the
situation and in a situation like this
with tons of big egos in the room it's
incredibly hard to do
because obviously
i think the first
you know the first thing that that is
tainting the situation of course is is
you know the fact that the interviews
and enhances extreme confidence and of
course this is not to some top
grandmaster's liking the gold standard i
think for discussing an issue like this
should be like anybody present even if
you feel very very strongly and you
let's say disagree with the way i'm
approaching the situation you should
feel that i'm being objective so
i'm gonna try to do that as much as
possible and if you adopt that mentality
i don't think there's actually much to
say i i'm going to say a series of
statements
and i believe all of these statements
are indisputable
and wherever you stand on the situation
whether you are will defend hans to your
grave
or you are absolutely convinced that he
is cheating
whichever side you you sit on
hopefully you can agree with these
statements
statement number one
there is no
hard evidence and i'll ex define what i
mean by hard evidence
to the
effect that hans is cheating over the
border has ever cheated over the board
and that that's statement one
that's not being disputed by anybody
if there was hard evidence and by hard
evidence i mean
somebody catching him in the act of
receiving assistance during an over the
board game that to my knowledge has not
happened nobody has come forward with
such evidence that evidence does not
exist
in the absence of
that evidence right that's like the gold
standard that's the kind of evidence you
would need in order to make a judgment
on how to proceed in order to ban
someone from a tournament let's say i
think where the majority of the conflict
has
has lied and this is interesting this is
different from a lot of these types of
cases where there is evidence and then
people are debating
you know the type of evidence like
johnny depp amber heard produced this
kind of photo what does this photo mean
so here one could say we have a similar
situation where there are a series of
things
that a lot of people are perceiving to
be red flags and i think the
disagreement lies
between people who think that they're
these things constitute like super
serious red flags on the basis of which
you can basically claim that it is going
on and then there are people who who say
that you're just falling prey to
confirmation bias and all of these
things are totally plausible
and uh you know saying that they're that
they're red flags is a complete witch
hunt um and we can
call this soft evidence i don't like to
even use the word evidence because this
is not evidence what goes under the
category of these things which some
people consider to be pretty damning and
other people think are
completely irrelevant and not indicative
of anything
and again just to be completely clear
what i'm about to say now is not
evidence that has nothing to do with
being evidence categorize this under red
flags i know that triggers some people
too because they think well red flags
that means you're saying that's evidence
even though no that's not what it means
thank you alaska chess for the five subs
we can debate labels forever you know
what i'm saying what falls under that
category so hans addressed a lot of
those things in his interview today
obviously there is the question of his
accent which is i would say tangent to
the bigger question i think we can all
agree and i have not been silent about
this that the accent is weird and uh we
can also all agree that debating the
accent and whether it's weird or not has
absolutely nothing to do
with the question of his play like these
are two completely separate issues and
people lumping them together are being
completely ridiculous
i like to imitate people i will
definitely imitate hans's accent i don't
give a [ __ ] i imitate everybody i invite
people to impersonate me i think hans
would be okay with me impersonating his
acts and i'm confident of it you know
i think eric on his stream discussed
this for a long time i don't have much
to add other than the fact that it's
definitely odd you know it kind of made
me raise my eyebrows but i don't see the
point in discussing the accent uh right
now because there's a much more
important topic to discuss okay now i'm
going to read the chat for a bit and
then i'm going to continue this is how
i'm going to structure this i'm going to
talk for a little then i'm going to read
the chat and then i'm going to keep
talking all things held equal
the fact that you have cheated online
makes it more realistic that you will
cheat over the board i'm not talking
about anybody specific here thank you
fedomeda for the 10 subs can we all
agree on that i'm pretty sure we can all
agree on that right if you conducted a
test of everybody who cheated over the
board
and you did a venn diagram i think we
can all make a pretty good faith guess
that you know more of them than not
would have turned out to be to be to
have cheated online we can all agree on
that no matter when you cheated online
whether it was at age 2 or at age 42
that fact you know there's the hole
where there's smoke there's fire idea
that fact makes it more likely
um that you will cheat over the board
now there could be a question that comes
from that which is is it then fair to
ask players who have high profile
players grandmasters who have cheated
online in the not so distant past is it
then fair for them to be requested
uh is it fair for them to be searched
let's say or treated
in a manner different from players who
have not been caught cheating online
well maybe maybe not that's a question
to explore for the future uh to avoid
this kind of situation okay um third
statement on this topic which is
if you cheat let's say at age nine or
ten that in some moral sense is a lot
more forgivable than cheating as an
adult i think we can all agree on that
statement as well and similarly we can
agree on the statement cheating in an
unrated online game or in a meaningless
online game as terrible as it is nobody
you know i've never hidden my stance on
cheating i i hate online people who
cheat online like i
it's a terrible act like blah blah blah
nobody disputes that either cheating in
let's say a money tournament you know is
a very very big deal especially for a
title player cheating in a meaningless
online game or you know checking the
computer once a middle game because you
want to hit some sort of rating rating
milestone as bad as that is
there are gradations of how bad cheating
is that to me that is indisputable as
well
which then begs the question well in
which situation did hans cheat because
if hanzo cheated let's say a title
tuesday or a money tournament
that to me would be incomparably more
like that would raise a lot more
eyebrows than what he seems to be
claiming in the interview which is that
he cheated a couple of times in
meaningless games when he was 12 and
when he was 16. so right now
the
you know what would be great in an on in
an ideal world is if we had an
understanding of exactly in which games
hans cheated how many times it happened
online and whether it happened in prize
tournaments now hans is telling the
truth and he never cheated in prize
tournaments and if he's you know telling
the entire truth and the only two times
he cheated when he was 12 and he was 16
um you know one would be more inclined
to believe his story that he is now is
understood um you know he's paid the
price for it through the ban and through
the fact that he didn't play money
tournaments you know he's
repented for his sins blah blah blah you
know he's a new man he's never doing it
again if that narrative you know is is
believable on its face period um and i
think the most important thing to
establish right now whether you know
who can help us establish the truth well
chess.com probably can i don't know what
the legal implications are here who can
reveal what but if we knew for a fact
what the record of hans online shooting
was i think that would help us determine
whether you know that that would help us
understand how much of a red flag the
online shooting is
now on rated i assume he means either
not money tournament or not i i'm not
entirely sure i feel like he was a
little bit muddled um so i would have
you know perhaps
somebody might you know give him uh
longer time to speak and this i i hope
will be clarified eventually in in short
order okay anybody who says hans is
obviously lying or hans obviously
telling the truth and i if you're like
that then i just throw my hands up then
i don't know what to say to you he did
say he cheated during oh he did he did
say cheating entitled tuesday because i
wasn't totally sure what what he was
saying i thought i thought he was a
little bit muddled than that yeah so
then there's the question of chess.com
removing hans and uninviting him to the
chess.com global championship uh to me
you know i obviously i work for
chess.com like i will remove myself from
the situation all i will say is that i i
hope that chess.com comes out with some
sort of a statement to clarify the
situation because and and the same i
think goes from agnes okay so now we'll
get to two other things that i have
written down here or three other things
the first is that i think a lot of
players especially those who are less
experienced consumers of chess content
when they hear
the term you know over the board
cheating
they think you know that's the most
outlandish thing ever there's very high
security at these top tournaments it
would be totally impossible to cheat
over the board in a tournament like this
that in itself another thing that i
think we can all agree i know you can
choose to trust my experience in the
chess world i've played in the saint
louis chess club many many times nine or
ten times by now
or you can think that i have a chip you
know i have an axe to grind and i'm
being biased but in my opinion
it is not particularly hard the way that
anti-cheating measures are set up right
now if you put your mind to it it is
possible to set up
a cheating mechanism even in very high
profile turn um even
in 2011
the first time that i played in the
st louis chess club the us championship
right back then
i mean
i would i would say bro i didn't i don't
think i didn't have a smartphone back
then um they weren't wanting or anything
back then most of the players didn't
have a smartphone but it occurred to me
there was a little balcony area in the
playing room in the san luis tresco if
you've seen photos you can probably see
it you can walk out into the balcony for
players who smoke um or just players who
want to get a fresh air a breath of
fresh air you can walk out into the
balcony so all of a sudden i'm sitting
there thinking how hard would it be for
an accomplice to be watching the games
sitting in their parked car in his or
her parked car
in the parking lot below the chest
center because the balcony looks out
into the parking lot and
at a predetermined time during the game
let's say at 1 30 at 2 and 2 30 you
would come out into the balcony and
receive a move signal from that person
the person walk out of his car and and
tell you what move to play and that is
like a super low tech thing
that one could have easily done like
through the years
and i know it sounds outlandish but
that is super low tech and then of
course there are
much more high-tech methods now there's
you know always the fear of an earpiece
i think that's
uh that's a big one something in your
shoes you know computers are getting
smaller and smaller and they're getting
harder and harder to detect if you trust
my experience then you should realize
that we aren't what we are not debating
here is like whether it is possible to
cheat over the board it is very possible
this happened very often um and it has
happened to even in quote unquote high
security tournaments and it happens in
you know the
phone in the bathroom method is not the
only way to do it okay so what else was
i going to say on that topic of
whether it's even possible to cheat at a
tournament like this yes hypothetically
it's possible and the scary thing is
that in recent years there have been
some cases of players who blatantly
cheating according to their moves but
nothing had ever been found i think the
most famous one was the case of a guy
named borislav ivanov he was a bulgarian
player in his twenties i think his
rating initially was something like
2100. don't quote me on it you can do
the google searches borislavinov started
beating like all these gm's like the
most blatant case of cheating you will
ever come across like a 2100 just
playing perfect literally every move was
a computer vote like he wasn't even
trying to hide it speeding absolutely
everybody you know there was as far as i
know their inspections nothing was ever
found i i think they even inspected his
shoes that creates this incredibly
thorny philosophical situation which is
okay what if you get a situation like
that where somebody is playing perfectly
or playing to a certain level you claim
that that level is absolutely impossible
it's as if a
street ball player would just walk onto
the court and beat lebron james in 10
one-on-one games consecutively you say
well that's impossible well where is
your proof that it's impossible what if
this person had spent the last five
years
um in their basement gym you know
working out and working on their shot
right unless you catch someone
right-handed there is no such thing as
100 proof there's just no way around
this
incredibly unfortunate truth
which is exactly what creates these
kinds of situations
okay on to the next topic which is
magnus's withdrawal
so
when magnus withdrew and i'm going to be
totally transparent here and to be clear
when i say the word suspicious i do not
mean
and i've said this on stream many times
if i'm suspicious of somebody does it
mean that i think they're a cheater in
some my people's minds the answer is yes
in my mind the answer is no you can be
suspicious of somebody without
having to
without necessarily having a clear
intuition that they're cheating i think
being suspicious somebody just means
you think they're exhibiting
uh an odd behavior you think that
something strange is going on but
you know you could be suspicious and
have no
idea what the actual truth is i think
that's that should be accepted
so when magnus withdrew from the
tournament it was immediately clear i
think to most gm's like what the reason
was i think if it would have been a
health reason
he would have stated that
so i think everybody immediately knew
what happened
which immediately begged the question um
this question was made even more central
by magnus's cryptic tweet which is um
like does magnus actually have proof
like if if he takes the unprecedented
act of withdrawing from a round-robin
tournament super serious thing to do
terrible thing to do if you don't have
an incredibly compelling reason for it
there have been a handful of times in
just history where someone has withdrawn
from a tournament i want to emphasize
how rare this is not just for magnus but
for anybody
anatoly karpov famously withdrew from a
tournament in the 90s his father passed
away um during the u.s championship one
time i think anna zatonski was true
because she had
serious medical problems she had to be
taken to the hospital like
unless it's one thing or the other thing
you just don't withdraw it's a breach of
contract you avoid your prize
it's a terrible look
in my mind
another statement that i hope we can all
agree on
which wherever you stand on
the question
it would be
a morally
questionable act to withdraw from a
tournament
unless you had very hard evidence
that
you know let's take the idea of
withdrawing as a sign of protest right
if there is a universe in which that act
is acceptable that universe is a
universe where you have super hard
evidence that you were cheated against
and with every passing day that magnus
doesn't clarify his stance
you know he looks worse and worse
because he's not providing any evidence
and
our magnus's hunches about people to be
taken seriously absolutely right
magnus has established himself as
someone who doesn't just throw words
around randomly so if magnus is
suspicious of someone or he thinks
something's going on that that should be
taken seriously
but if that was indeed magnus's position
i think that would be an acceptable
position
but why then didn't he
have an earnest talk with the organizers
request for
you know more stringent searches
whatever you know x y and z
how do you go from there to withdrawing
from the tournament and not providing a
reason that's really what i don't
understand i can't get over that
to me
um unless magnus comes forward with
something like super super concrete and
none of what i laid out in the category
of red flags
comes anywhere near
i think a justification for withdrawing
losing
to hans doesn't j
you know
isn't a reason because the game itself i
think we've all established
is not outside the ordinary that i think
is another
statement that is pretty much
not subject to dispute all grandmasters
who have analyzed the game carefully
have
said that there isn't anything overly
suspicious about the game there were
quite a few mistakes i looked at the
game myself it's a very good game
magnus played below his level no
question about it it is an extraordinary
result
but
if you just gave me that game on its own
i would never
suspect that the person playing with
either colors
black of course was was cheating it's
just not one of those games where you
look at it and you're like man you know
you didn't feel like you were playing a
human
what was more suspicious to me initially
was definitely the interviews if you
know you want to know what weirded me
out the most by far it was not the
results
you know it's not necessarily the fact
that hans has been improving at a
ridiculous pace which is
unprecedented for sure but so was like
stephen curry
you know disrupters come along
um
in the chess world i mean and and
there have been plenty of flares with
incredibly sharp improvement curves so
we can get into that separately
what am i talking about right now
yes so the interviews so to me the only
thing that really weirded me out
when this situation was unfolding were
the interviews
now there's a lot of confirmation bias
that relay and i hope i'm being coherent
if i'm not please stop me
what specifically did i find weird about
the universe i think a lot of
people who have watched the interviews
have fallen into confirmation bias and
are like this is weird this is weird
yeah the fact that han said no instead
of yes in this moment means that he's
cheating
i i think that we need to
calm the [ __ ] down
um because
it is very true
that after let's say a game of the world
champion you are tired you are less
equipped to verbalize your thoughts
clearly that is all totally true
everybody can agree with that
but obviously hans
wasn't just like tired and
not really engaged like that was really
the tip of the iceberg and
his analysis during those two interviews
three interviews was and his way of
presenting his thoughts
definitely was strange
another thing that i think even if you
are
i'm going out into the streets and
defending haunts i think you can still
agree with that right that the
interviews
were odd that doesn't mean i'm saying
they were just odd in and of themselves
it is definitely true that you know some
of the mistakes he made in the analysis
i won't go into it right now you can
find plenty of like live reacts you can
watch the interviews for yourselves
there were moments when i raised my
eyebrows i was like man that's like an
oversight
you know i'd be surprised if a player of
his caliber would be making
in a position like this he seemed
uncertain of certain conclusions and
very overly certain of certain other
conclusions when i thought the
evaluation was
a lot more complicated he seemed to be
suggesting that certain things were slam
dunk when in fact they weren't
um another thing that i found a little
bit odd was in his game against
in his gaming as carlson
um there was a draw that magnus had
it's an admittedly difficult draw
yeah there was there was just a lack of
coherence
in the way that hans was presenting his
thoughts that is uncharacteristic of a
player at that level giving press
conferences i had never heard
um of that kind of thing before
doesn't necessarily tell us anything but
anyways
there was a moment
where magnus could have traded the
bishop for the night so hans played
knight c4 he was very defensive about
this move
f takes g4 was the best move
rook takes e4 f5 i looked at this a
little bit the sun game should be
winning for black
and the last thing i'll talk about after
this of course is han's personality and
his comments and what you're saying
alaska chess i'll address that lastly
so hans plays knight c4 and this gives
magnus this weird drawer he takes on c4
maybe you remember this g takes f5 now
han said calculated up to rook a4 and
thought okay i'm winning the a pawn i
get
connected passers which is generally
you know a surefire sign of a win but
here white has this idea
of going rook v8
forcing b5 and sticking the rook on b6
and this creates a force field the black
king simply cannot join the the action
and on their owns the pawn pawns are not
moving forward this is a very
for a gm this is a pretty rudimentary
idea this kind of construction where
like the pawns cannot pull themselves up
by the bootstraps
and it's pretty obvious once you reach
this position in your mind that
you know it's not obvious that this is a
draw but it is obvious that white has
like excellent drawing chances as it
turns out it is a draw
but when they reached this position in
the analysis hans was totally convinced
that black is completely winning here
and in fact he thought that the king
gets to f6 by force when in fact it
doesn't
and i would expect the gm when they
reach this position on the board to see
rugby around b6 pretty another thing
that
i kind of thought was odd
and again i want to return to the
initial point if hans is watching this
right now i would hope
and he would acknowledge that you know
that
he would see it from the perspective of
let's say a grandmaster is watching this
and thinking that it is odd this is
something you should see if you're 2700
period
right
again not evidence doesn't necessarily
say anything at all in and of itself
so there were
quite a few moments like this during the
interviews where i was just like well
it seems strange to me you know that
hans isn't presenting his thoughts about
the game in a
clear and coherent manner and he's you
know making calculation mistakes
and uh you know that that to me really
was the only thing that that raised my
my suspicions but in the absence of any
other
evidence i mean just taken in and of
itself this does not give you the right
to make any accusations whatsoever
and i found hans explanations today to
be pretty plausible
so again right now it tosses the ball
right back into like magnus's court
where you know i like the expression
[ __ ] or get off the pot like
either you
have something to to say in response to
what han said or
you've got no further evidence and life
goes on
okay so
in terms of hanz's personality
another thing that
is negative about okay this is a
criticism of hans
one which again i would hope he would
find to be reasonable
which is that
you know the way he was talking about
the top players like the second third
round and who am i to police how people
should be talking in press conferences
nobody
but it really did seem that he was
crossing some lines in regards to like
and i i really do believe that it was
some of the things he said were pretty
disrespectful and i don't see how else
to phrase it
there's plenty of athletes who are super
self-confident i don't know i don't
think anybody begrudges someone
self-confidence
but you know there's no question that he
kind of went overboard and you know all
these these players top players suck and
like
you know the world champion should be
embarrassed losing to me like that that
to me is is very juvenile and
unnecessary and it was very annoying to
hear that
but i still think that a lot of people
are letting that annoyance
uh permeate their
you know influence their perception of
you know
whether whether hans is cheating i
really believe that
and i believe that
what he said was you know in certain
situations was annoying to hear
you know i would hope that he
kind of realizes that you can be
confident you can be
a disrupter without you know tacking on
you know these additional petty things
he's not violating the law i mean last i
checked it's a free country you can save
whatever the hell you want after the
game
and you know if you just be magnus
carlson then
you've got the
you know you're walking the walk
so
you know his behavior on stream
previously and during the interviews
again
is odd at times it's rough boorish
one could say maybe even disrespectful
in certain cases it pisses a lot of
people off but if you're one of those
people who are pissed off
you have to realize that this is
separate from the question of whether he
used assistance over the board these are
two completely different things you may
say that
the talking in the way that he talked
makes you more likely
to cheat maybe that's true maybe that's
not true but that doesn't advance the
conversation
in terms of what i think will happen
next what should happen next
magnus needs to shoot or get off the
punt i think he needs to come forward
with the statement i'm sure there's
legal
authority legal things involved but
the bottom line is that he needs to
clarify why he withdrew
the situation between chess.com and hans
should be resolved ideally
i think the public should know
at which tournaments hans cheated when
he cheated in order for us to be able to
corroborate the story that he presented
today
um but again in the absence of
magnus coming forward i think he looks
bad
and you know i think that
ultimately we just have to ask is there
hard evidence or not and if the answer
is no
then the answer is no
oh yeah so the preparation is another
thing
yeah that was another thing that i think
almost everybody found to be weird the
way that hans was talking about it
obviously he made that
mistake which a lot of people made a big
deal out of that they had no game in the
2018 london classic
now g3 you know predicting a line like
this that the same morning
it is
vanishingly unlikely
now i'm surprised like
even if it was some sort of like if i
would have wanted to hide a leak what i
would have said is just like i checked
this before the tournament that would be
like totally understandable this is not
an unheard of line if you play the nimzo
indian full time you should know how to
play against g3
so
you know
i i i don't know i i don't know if hans
is telling the truth or not about
about uh discovering
or about preparing
this line that that morning
it is possible like again i think if
somebody like hosted hans on a stream
let's say not saying that will ever
happen anybody would ever do that
but uh this would be a question that i
think one could press him on further and
really ask him like you know
hypothetically would you be able to go
into your chest space and chest space
keeps a record of
what you looked at every day like would
you would this line actually pop up on
your chest base
um you know so so that's
definitely a weird
weird thing that happened
um in a later interview hans mentioned
that this arises via transposition out
of the catalan
that
is more plausible bishop before check
knight c3 this line
so by transposition you get i guess dc
but should you two castles and a3
um so this could appear could have been
hanza's preparation as well
okay looking at chat
but i think this is a microcosm of
where we are where we are at and our
ability to
consider complex topics fairly and
unemotionally which is
we are in
i think we're just in trouble as a
society because we just cannot seem to
it just seems like our our
emotional nature and the fact that we
want
and we want our opinion to get out there
above all else it's like more important
to state your opinion on social media
tack on whichever camp you're at then
just patiently lay out the evidence and
say the words i don't know because
i think every single person in the world
right now
should be in the i don't know camp and
should be in the camp of lake a couple
of weird things happened we probably
need more explanation on those weird
things partially from hans himself
but those weird things do not form
evidence that he cheated over the board
what's your opinion on hikaru
well i know hikaru has his strong
opinions
not my business to
criticize him or
support him
you know he
he laid out his thoughts pretty clearly
and uh that's his that's his prerogative
i'll let him do his thing and i will do
mine
uh my personal opinion is that
hikaru has definitely you know
he did jump to certain conclusions
pretty quickly
and i i get it i get that in the heat of
the moment you know these these
you know you start seeing these red
flags in these interviews and if you
already if you've already formed an
opinion beforehand then this is just
like classic confirmation yeah obviously
he couldn't have done this this and this
you know i i personally don't
totally agree with hikara's approach but
we're both adults and we both do our own
thing and i ultimately think the truth
will come out and people
will eventually settle on the right side
of the issue
housekeeping 22 says when hans played in
a tournament that he didn't have access
to the engine he got zero out of 21. but
in classical tournaments that he can use
bathroom during the games he gains plus
200 so what i would say to that is
they do want you before the you can't
carry a phone into the route they want
you from hand to foot
right it's very very hard to
get anything into the into the playing
hall
also hans did not get zero to 21 right
if you actually look at the mattress he
was winning a lot of games in those
matches he beat carlson once he didn't
win any matches but he won plenty of
games within those individual matches
what everybody seems to be forgetting
about his ftx cup is that his
performance rating if you take the
actual results rather than the match
results was basically consistent with
his rating i think his performance
rating was like in the 2600s which i
know he was incredibly disappointed by
but is a pretty normal result for
someone of his rating
so i don't think his performance the ftx
cup is necessarily
weird when when contrasted with this one
you know it's it's it's plausible it's
very misleading to say that he lost all
21 games that would be different you
know you lose 21 games in a row you come
to the next tournament you all of a
sudden beat magnus and mommy jarv i
could begin to see some weirdness there
still would not be any evidence at all
you can't hide a phone in the bathroom
trust me they inspect the bathrooms
after each round they clean the
bathrooms multiple times a day in st
louis
it's hard to pull shenanigans unless
it's high-tech like it would have to be
an earpiece or something in the shoe
and you know obviously the understanding
throughout chess history has been
if you do that and you get caught like
you're ruined for life so that is in
itself is a deterrent to doing that
but in recent months as online chess has
grown we've seen players get more
desperate
we've seen players get more desperate
and you know unfortunately we've seen
that that isn't really a deterrent
what if i took two paper cups and a
piece of string to the bathroom
constructed phone from it to talk to
stockfish build your own phone
okay looking at other chat messages
consider our perspective says charlie
kind of him we know absolutely nothing
about top level chess we hear many top
generations indicating they are sus on
hans so we believe them totally fair
um
and this is where i think
it's so important to be nuanced and to
realize that you know these top players
are also in the middle of the tournament
so emotions are already running high to
begin with right you have to understand
that
the second thing you have to understand
is that in most cases they don't have
access to any information that you don't
have access to right they're going by
the same evidence quote unquote that you
are which which are the games and the
interviews
and you don't really honestly have to be
that good of a chess player to make your
conclusions based on that
so i wouldn't put too much stock in what
and i i know this sounds very arrogant
of me to say but like these post-game
interviews and the hot takes
from you know rooney and nepo
i wouldn't put too much stock in them
because i think there's a lot of emotion
there
there's not a lot of nuance and a
one-sentence answer
and um you know unless these players sit
down and do a youtube video or something
where they analyze the games and say
exactly why they're suspicious
i feel like it's just another voice in
the ocean of voices that aren't actually
offering any substance but are merely
saying
you know what everybody else
knows to be true yeah obviously the top
players are going to be suspicious you
know a guy nobody heard of three years
ago
has just defeated the world champion you
know he
is close to winning the tournament
obviously you know the top players are
going to be some of them are going to be
butt hurt
to begin with and
you know hans
arrogance is going to stoke the flames
of that more i honestly don't think that
some of these top guys coming out and
saying they're suspicious is really
surprising behavior at all i think
that's completely like
understandable par for the course
um and i wouldn't put too much stock in
it but i understand why like people's
opinions flip-flop so much first you
hear nepo saying something then you hear
aronian defending him then you hear
jacob bogart coming out and writing this
piece then you hear magnus so you keep
flip-flopping like who do i believe
well
it's it's just that nobody actually
knows
and uh your guess is as good as you know
magnus's guess
um does he doesn't hikara is a popular
content creator arguably a
responsibility to present that nuance
you know that you know my position on
any issue i think any person of the
voice has a responsibility to be nuanced
and objective in their approach of an
issue no matter what their personal
relationship is whether it's positive or
negative with the person involved
but i also believe that
you know it's a you know twitch is a
free platform
free in the sense that it's free to
consume but also free
in the sense that you can basically say
whatever you want you can take different
approaches
and if you don't like the approach
someone is taking you should
watch them right you should
you know optimize your
entertainment by choosing the people
whose approach
you find to be
most reasonable
um
i disagree with ikaro's approach on many
issues i've made that very clear
doesn't mean that i haven't maintained a
positive working relationship with him
which i have
um
but yeah i you know again um
i'm not hiding the fact that as [ __ ] was
going down i
you know i was suspicious i i saw that
magnus with drew and i was like the
first thing that i thought you can
burn me at the stake for this i you know
because of the incredibly good
reputation that magnus has
i thought there must be a reason for
this you know he would never do such a
thing unless he had hard evidence
right and that's the first thing that i
thought but as time went on and magnus
didn't come forward
you know i started to realize that that
might not be the actual
story it might very well be the case
that magnus did something very hasty
and did something out of frustration
without fully considering
the implications of his action
um
especially given the fact that people
are much more likely to believe someone
like magnus or hicaro as opposed to hans
okay what else do i have to say
now i could give you a compliment
because of glimpses of brilliancy said
to you about earlier well i appreciate
that
um let's see what else
people have been saying
alaska chess says aunts cannot cry foul
at this point created his own problems
players have no obligation to overlook
his fast shooting suspicious behavior
agree the onus is on hans to earn the
trust of his peers and chess fans and
he's failing miserably at that on all
accounts
so i agree with
what you're saying well this is what we
established initially if someone has
cheated online does it make it okay to
be suspicious of that person if they are
turning in an incredible over-the-board
person in my opinion absolutely
right and how can you argue that right
if somebody has a record
you we've established it at the very
start we all agreed on that
i think where you're going wrong you're
seemed you seem to be suggesting that
certain personality traits
um
you know are canceling out hans's
ability to defend himself and fair i
disagree i think you're conflating two
different issues
i think we should keep hanzo's
personality and like what he says
vis-a-vis like the top players
completely separate from
you know the question of his actual play
um
i don't think that he's going to be
liked by
you know most if not all of the top
players
you know probably for a while
especially if he continues you know
with the same type of interview but i
also don't think he gives a [ __ ]
you know i think he cares a lot more
about his rating and you know his
results so
upset with someone on history was
invited in the first place that the
sinful cup deserved someone scandal free
well um
can you give an example of a reason i'll
get to that in a second
that someone would be suspicious of
cheating in an otb tournament without
hard evidence well the classic is like
somebody getting up all the time
um just
there's certain things that a person can
be doing during the game a weird
spectator who seems to be watching the
game all the time is a big one
um
you know obviously
an unrated player having six out of six
in a tournament is going to make you
suspicious
to begin with and i think all that's
totally okay
um
but
in terms of whether
you should invite
somebody with a past record here's the
thing magnus knew who they had invited
he signed the contract and agreed to
play in the tournament
um you know knowing that hans would be
playing and i'm pretty sure that he was
aware of hans's history
and you know you can't then say oh well
actually you know
um i don't want to play with somebody
who's cheated before online and then
then that begs the question where do we
draw the line let's say someone cheated
let's say hanzo's story is true right he
cheated at 16 should he be punished
forever should he never be invited to
a top tournament even if he's proven
himself worthy on the board doesn't that
violate you know the idea that we should
be inviting players based on their
merits not based on their personalities
um i also think hanzo's a last-minute
replacement that might be true because
of report
tons of top uh title players have
cheated online by the way
and if we went by the rule of like not
you know associating ourselves with
title players who cheated or strong
players who cheated online it would just
be a total [ __ ] show
[Music]
but i i i want to just maintain that i
really do think that
the title player cheating online is is
almost as bad as title player cheating
like a title player cheating period
is despicable in my opinion that
that is a much more serious
transgression to me than you know
someone who's like
a beginner a casual player maybe doesn't
understand the implications of cheating
like those are two completely different
kettle of fish
um
and but but let's put your put yourself
if you had ever cheated online would you
admit it well
i would like to think that i would
did you watch i also
you know wouldn't
my reason for not cheating is pretty
selfish i think it's just the fact that
i
i'm too selfish i want the
accomplishment all for myself you know i
want the feeling that i did it entirely
on my own
um
let's see what kavita says yeah i think
we should wait for magnus's statement
before you know shoveling dirt on
anybody
i agree that a pass should not define
somebody permanently
i think that
you know if you're in hanzo shoes and
you're trying to clear your name you
know the fact that he agreed to submit
himself to any kind of search is
you know a point in his favor
now you could say well that's clearly
performative because like
the organizers are not in a position to
demand that search of that kind so hans
knows it's not going to happen and he's
trying to curry some favor
by saying that but i don't know how much
that's true
um
this has gone on way longer than 15 20
minutes well i knew it would
we're bringing this to an end within a
couple of minutes
but it's a it's a big you know this is
this is what's going on right now in the
chess world
okay there's a lot of people
brief queen g3 thoughts
let's see
yeah i think regardless of
you know how the situation resolves i
have been saying this for a long time so
this isn't just like
a reaction
to what's happening now
um
anti-cheating measures nikita vitsugov
very strong russian gm he made a
post about this in russian
anti-cheating measures at the very top
tournaments have to be more stringent it
just can't be you have to move forward
with the times
and it can't just be you know wanting it
they have to find some way to detect ear
pieces and like
see i'm not an expert on this but i'm
sure that if you put heads together and
given the funds that let's say the st
louis chess club has that there are ways
to
really close all of the avenues to the
point where
for someone to cheat he would need to be
basically like a cia agent
and i think that's that's okay like
because this is
a problem and pretending that this isn't
a problem or that you know just because
you're a top player you're immune from
suspicion is
you know is is not right
um how can you tell the difference
between somebody improving rapidly due
to hours and hours of study under the
pandemic and somebody improving rapidly
due to external assistance well that's
another big question because hans
improved very rapidly in two years
if we check his feed a page
um
which i have open here
and if you've asked your question and i
haven't answered it just please be
patient there's chat is going a million
miles an hour
um
now magnus may have given a reason to
sing field cup organizers in private but
he hasn't provided one in public
okay what if magnus knows what cheating
looks like because he cheats himself
queen g300 did give me a second relax i
will provide my thoughts on queen she
three but you can see hans was 2465 for
a while in 2020
and then he went
24 to 25 hundreds
then he hung out at 25 low 2500s for a
bit then
it was 2600 in 2021 august
2020 august he was 24.65 so that's
140 points in a year
um but i also had a pretty steep growth
from 24 to 2 600.
but then he went 2609 2021 september
2022 september
it was 26.88 so that growth from 2606 to
26.88 is pretty crazy so in a year he
won 160 points if we compare that to me
to my my shameful
career
then you'll see that i went from
yeah i've been 2600 for a while but i
went i
i wouldn't say that i did something
overly too dissimilar to that i went
2472
in 2013 april
yeah i mean in 2014
and in 2014 september i was i was 26 or
26 20 in november
so
you know i did i guess i did what he did
in one year in two years but it's also
because i played a lot less and i had
many months where i didn't play
so i think that the growth is very steep
but it's not
crazy to the point where i would not
believe in principle that if somebody
was working hard
that they would be able to do that um
then there's the jacob agrippos now
jacob i think eric
made some good points on this
let's not pretend that jacob is unbiased
and whatever you think of his points
that he made in his blog post clearly
jacob is biased which is okay you're
allowed to be biased
clearly he's not a fan of magnus's
behavior maybe not a fan of magnus in
general
which is also okay you can like and
dislike whoever you want
but there was a lot in that article that
i thought was the product of some you
know emotional connection
which is understandable
none of what
jacob's i mean
you know jacob mentioned basically the
gist of what he said is that hans you
know worked incredibly hard and he can
confirm that
and i think at this point it is clear
that hans did invest like a huge amount
of time into into his own improvement
um
that
as a standalone fact though doesn't like
advance the conversation
because then one could say yeah well
maybe he's
you reach 25 2600 level on his own but
you know that extra assistance is
bringing him over 2700
i think that
one interesting
way forward would be in an interview
let's say with hans to ask him more
specific to elaborate on
what it is that he was doing like he
claims that he's training 10-12 hours a
day like could you
outline a sample day like what would you
be doing exactly for those 10 hours
um you know can you provide
some specific evidence of like what it
is you did that improved your level from
what did you do from 2600 to 2680
specifically like can you reveal who you
worked with what did you do with them
you know
how do you
to what do you attribute your rapid
growth you know what do you think pushed
you over the edge
and i think hans should also elaborate
on his intuitive approach to the game
because you can have an intuitive
approach to chess
but at that level you still need to
calculate a [ __ ] ton of variation so i
don't buy
the whole like
i can play without calculating anything
like that to my knowledge that's not a
um
you know
you cannot cross 2 700 without being
just a calculational monster
if hans wins the tournament many
participants express their suspicions
again wouldn't he be branded for the
future even without any proof yeah
that's an unfortunate
that's that's the potentially
unfortunate situation which could arise
in the absence of a smoking gun that he
treated is it logically okay to trust
the collective judgment of top players
the next best thing especially if they
are otherwise fierce competitors well
general
you would
i don't know of a
you know better thing than that but the
reason this is such a thorny topic is
because
there are very few experts on over the
board cheating it really genuinely is so
incredibly hard to say
whether somebody is playing honestly if
they're already strong to begin with or
whether somebody's getting
assistance two or three times a game
another thing i've made clear before if
you're 2600 to begin with
if you gave me three opportunities to
look at a computer eval during an over
the board game
then i would probably cross 2700 would
be my guess and i think this is an
opinion shared by a lot of like top
teams like if you gave me two or three
engine moves at critical moments i
wouldn't really need more than that to
to cross 2700 so a lot of people have
this distorted view where they think
well
how could he be cheating like is he
getting moves every single game um in
any case of over-the-board cheating
where the player is already strong to
begin with those of course are the
always the hardest cases to detect
is it an existential threat to trust
well some situation like this is a
serious serious uh threat to maybe not
to chess itself like chess will continue
right tournaments will not be canceled
over this
chess at most levels will continue but
this this threatens to drive a stake
into like the overall
reputation of the chess world the
reputation of top players
it's an unpleasant situation for
everybody involved nobody is benefiting
from the situation not a single person
to me that's always the sign of a deeply
like toxic situation where like there
isn't anybody who stands to benefit from
it
um you know this is this is hurting the
collective chess world
uh the fact that this is happening
and and the problem is it's not
necessarily anyone's fault specifically
it is true that cheating itself is just
a big issue that needs to be reckoned
with
um and it's it's sad that this issue
exists but that issue is going to cause
situations like this to happen
um
and to me it was like a matter of time
before a situation like this would arise
unfortunately it has arisen
hikaru benefits all the drama and
youtube date yeah i mean people who want
to benefit via youtube bait i mean
that's again that's that's
did you talk about the possibility of
magnus's prep leaking i don't think that
is a serious possibility
for that to happen somebody would have
had to message hans what magnus was
planning to play that morning
i find that tremendously impossible what
does it probably even mean like all of
his prep magnus's prep isn't like
contained on one computer that says
magnus is prep on it these are like
hundreds of chess-based database
databases some of which he has in his
possession some of which presumably his
team has you can't just like
preparation isn't just like one you know
people think of like a printout that is
given to somebody or a packet that's not
what it looks like
i i
find that theory to be very implausible
um queen g3 i know a lot of people are
very excited about
queen g3
so what do i think of queen g3 in the
uh
neiman ferrugia game so alireza seemed
to say that this was
he was shocked at this move and how
quickly it was played
it is the top mo top choice i think of
stockfish
okay he spent how long in this move he
spent uh one minute according to the
chess.com timestamp but he spent 12
minutes on e5
no i i don't understa i mean i honestly
don't feel like this move was insane
if you see okay so why would it be
insane it's because it's actually night
but bishop h6 g6
what you really would have to see here
is either bishop g5 or maybe i think as
hans pointed out he
well if you believe him then he he
largely made an intuitive judgment i
think he gave a line like this queenie
yane and he mentioned this idea of rook
takes d7 and bishop f6 that's not hard
to see in a couple of seconds
so f6 is very clearly forced and then
you get this position bishop h6 which is
a total mess
to me this is a findable move i i really
i know some people are
like really hoping that i'm about to say
that this is
a computer move and somebody who plays
squishy is obviously a cheater
but
no and the other question is well what
else are you going to do if you're
already playing e5
what other move are you going to make in
this position are you really going to
drop your knight back to d2
knight d6 is a tactical blunder because
of knight takes e5 black wins upon
so if you're spending 12 minutes on e5
it's very clear to me that he wasn't
really calculating e5 he was calculating
this position
i do not find that impossible i mean 12
minutes on this move yeah he spent one
minute on queen g3 but at that point the
decision had already been made
and there are many situations
i can speak from experience even as a gm
where i just say [ __ ] it and i make the
move
like not every decision is always
perfectly calculated this is how some
people think of gm chess it's like every
move is calculated to the end of the
game like not at all you are making
these bluff moves pretty pretty commonly
and in this case hans predicted the
evaluation correctly
um
so
i i would not
concentrate my the root of my suspicions
on queen g3
i honestly think this is a example of
confirmation bias
you already think someone's cheating
i've done this before
i've been suspicious of somebody so then
every move they play
and this is true of other things in life
as well right everything that somebody
does if you don't like somebody is
annoying
right it's it's the same with this right
you think they're cheating every move
they play oh this must mean that they're
cheating they played this move in one
minute instead of 10
like that no human could have ever done
that
so here i would really really caution
you to be very careful about you know
overly over analyzing moves and saying
you're policing like how long someone's
supposed to spend on a complicated move
even if stacking a piece against twenty
eight hundred not following a deep
analysis well the thing is
i think hans we've established that he's
a
he's an intuitive player as a fearless
player
and he's a player who's willing to take
risks
so this type of decision it's not one
that i would make personally i would be
terrified to play this move against
ferruccia but
i could see how you know if this was a
predetermined strategy that hunts had
adopted before this game i don't
remember who made this flight but faruga
doesn't like to be attacked
you know if russia has a weakness it's
probably defending
so if this is an insight that hanzo made
during before the game then it would
make sense
that he tried to put this additional
pressure
um
ferruccia called this move insane but
okay but
what conclusions do you make from that
so for you know it is an impressive idea
but
i i don't i wouldn't necessarily call
this move insane
um you know it's just you just cannot
say that just because the 2800 found
didn't see a move then
that means the guy who found the moves
is cheating let's say
um hans mentioned that oh oh han said
that it was insane
or no
i don't know who said that
yeah ferruccio didn't see in sequel g3
nepo had similar things in his youth
you're right
nepa was like this too he was playing
really quickly
in critical moments
very often recklessly so
um so this this type of thing is not
unprecedented
let's see ohan said that ellie reza
doesn't like being attacked but that's
true
though hans himself said that well
that's a true statement i think that's
uh that's pretty clear
um i think that's that's a true true
assessment
if magnus never walks back his words
what happens i assume you mean if he
never gives a reason or walks back his
words what would future tournaments know
i don't think magnus is going to be
disinvited for future tournaments he's
too big of a name
um
if
it turns out that you know let's say
hans is not in not cheating should
magnus be punished
i honestly don't know i i just wish that
um
i mean i just don't know i don't know
what should happen um
magnus has had a very good reputation
like before all of this he's
established himself as a fighter someone
who doesn't
jump to conclusions
supportive of up-and-coming players so
again i think the next step before we
even talk about like meeting up
punishments is
we wait for magnus to issue
a statement that
is literally
all we can do
what can magnus actually say at this
point to justify his withdrawal well if
he doesn't have concrete evidence
i think the best thing for magnus would
be to lay out exactly why he thought why
he was so convinced
that hans was cheating like to lay it
out point by point
you know what were the the red flags and
you know if he observed something during
the game that disturbed him i think if
magnus were to be honest about that
you know would there be better
there would be a chance that people
would you know understand where he's
coming from
do you think nepal meant anything
serious by more than impressive i
thought it was a genuine compliment well
you never know is it a compliment or is
he insinuating something that's what i
said earlier about not taking these hot
takes of the top players too seriously
let's be real nepo foruga running they
have not analyzed sansa's games for this
tournament seriously i just wouldn't put
all that much stock into their
into their takes um
i just would not um
you know i i just wouldn't form my
opinions based on the opinion of
somebody else who's embroiled in their
own tournament
can you outline what high level prep
looks like as to why leaking isn't
feasible
well when you say leaking right leaking
like there was a case i think
many years ago of i think timur java of
getting his laptop stolen
and and uh what that could mean
right what if what does that even mean
like
well generally a player these top
players they have chess space and they
have databases that contain opening
files
and these opening files are a roadmap
for what they're going to play in real
games so
when we talk about preparing for someone
you're trying to predict what they're
going to play based on what they're what
they've played before
and then generally you review the files
that you and your team have created
based on the openings that you think is
going to happen
so i can give you an example let's say
that i'm playing
you know i'm playing joe schmoe
and you know joe schmoe
plays
um
the french defense of black right
so i'm looking around at my files do i
have a file on the french that i can
review before the game
well yes i do i have this file in the
win hour
so i spend two hours reviewing
this french file that i have i'll
display it on the screen really briefly
to show you like what a file even looks
like really because a lot of people use
that word file
and people who are less
chess experienced in the chess world
are not never sure like what that means
just give me a second as
okay
so this is what a file
looks like
now
files differ from player to player but
the bottom line is that you just like
have a complete analysis of a variation
and yes i am like displaying some of my
analysis here
i don't really care it's fine um
clarifying is more important i think
so this is
this is i would say not
nearly as high level of a file as some
of these top players have like they are
their files are crazy crazy deep
everything is laid out every variation
is analyzed
but this is what leaked prep would look
like
you can see that there's text there's
analysis you're analyzing all the top
lines and
if hans would
or anybody were to receive let's say a
file like this and this were magnus's
file
um
that wouldn't necessarily give you all
that much information because that
wouldn't necessarily mean that magnus
would play this particular line
so for the leaked prep theory to work
you would have to not only leak a
particular file but leak the exact file
that represents the line that let's say
magnus is going to play in the next game
not just some random file
but
once opening collection is like a series
of these types of files that's all it is
right analysis of various openings files
that contain moves that you are going to
play the next time you have that opening
that's really all there is to it
evaluating misevaluating a position
happens all the time if the position is
complex the about misevaluations can be
quite severe
even for the strongest players like it's
very common to evaluate a position as
being winning when it's equal or vice
versa evaluation is one of the hardest
skills in chess looking at a complicated
position saying who's better
is one of the biggest reasons why
engines are so much stronger than us
they can do that flawlessly
and evaluating a position properly gives
you a road map that tells you like
whether you should be playing
defensively or aggressively
but
it's a weakness for some players and the
strength and others i know
some very strong gm's who whose
evaluational skills
you know are not great comparatively
like they
don't always have a great sense of
whether they're better or worse in a
position but
you can make it you know you can become
a very strong player really even without
having that skill right that that skill
is doesn't directly
prevent you not having that skill
doesn't directly prevent you from
finding the best move you don't always
need to analyze evaluate the position
properly to find the best move
um they're two like separate things
but yeah
another thing that everybody has to
understand really you have to understand
this which is that you know gm's are
human
they blunder during analysis they
blunder during real games like just
because you've spent years and years on
chess doesn't mean that you're immune
from like dumb mistakes
or or basic oversight so just seeing
somebody blunder a piece during analysis
doesn't automatically oh they must be
cheating during the game because a real
grandmaster would have never blundered
like this in the analysis
okay so
what i'm saying is that people are still
wondering about like how over-the-board
cheating can actually happen in the
presence of security measures i've
already talked about that several times
there are devices that are harder to
detect
earpieces
computers hidden in shoes there's
there's tiny computers that you can hide
on your body
there's all sorts of stuff i mean if you
look around there's there's you know
technology is improving and
you know
you can research this this is not
exclusive to chess right cheating on
exams in school and stuff
i you know i think some complex methods
have been developed for that too and
there's a you know
i would imagine the mechanism could be
pretty similar
i think what ultimately is going to
happen unless
you know
evidence that proves or disproves comes
out
what probably will end up happening is
unfortunately there just will be people
who would think that he cheated and
people who think he didn't and
you know hopefully
you know that there is a truth out there
you know it is one or the other and
you know through
interviews with hans himself and more uh
you know
evidence that will come out from team
magnus and you know teamfest.com and
stuff
hopefully we can
approach closer to the truth but i think
this will
that this might
you know be a very sore spot for many
many months maybe years to come
you know especially if hans's career
goes forward in the same
successful manner that it has gone
forward the last couple of years
it's too early to make these judgments
because the situation is still unfolding
that's what i'm going to say
hasn't magnus earn enough respect to
walk away from anything without
explanation well magnus can do as he
pleases right
nobody can
barring legal issues like
you can do as you wish like magnus can
choose not to ever provide an
explanation like does that then mean
that he should never be invited to
another tournament i i don't know like i
don't know
what that would
mean that would definitely tarnish his
reputation
but
what does it even mean that one's
reputation is tarnished what are the
actual things that that leads to who the
hell knows
if
hans were to not be invited to
tournaments subsequently
due to you know the suspicion alone and
no further evidence comes out
that i think would be
in violation of the basic spirit of the
game
so in conclusion then
i will say that the situation is very
very complicated
like danny king said in his recap there
is like
there's no hard evidence there are
you know reasons to be suspicious
and i think we have disagreement on what
it means to say that you're suspicious
it doesn't mean that you think that
someone is cheating it just means you
think that there is
you know there are strange things going
on that require further explanation that
that's all that that really means
um
and finally the fact that hans has
cheated online before
nobody disputes that that
you know contributes to that overall
aura of
strangeness
and
you know that then would
raise the bar for one could say for like
how han should clear his name
you know um
it it
tosses the ball more firmly into your
court
but one could then argue that hans did
that today
and
in the absence of further evidence and
further explanations like
you know his stance is pretty compelling
so
we're gonna find
you know more stuff is gonna come out in
the future
in the next couple of days i would
encourage people to be calm online and
just like
resist the urge to pile on
but you'll get your chance to ask more
questions in future streams is not the
last time i'll talk about this
so just be patient you know let's wait
for the facts
and uh let's remind ourselves like why
we're in the chess world to begin with
um hopefully
this resolves itself quickly
thank you everybody appreciate it good
talk see y'all later
[Music]